I think the internet has genuinely
corrode people's ability to communicate with others
it has made everyone view others as so disposable
that they are not worth a conversation
like watching creators come on to the internet and like
cause drama and strife when you could just pick up a phone
send a little text
every time I see a creator bring interpersonal beef to the internet
that could have been handled personally because like
you were connected to this person
you were friends something
it's just like
watching it is really embarrassing and just like
it's like sad because like
you can't even speak to this person like a human being
you needed the public so badly to be involved into this
in this issue when you could have resolved it
like what happened to conflict resolution
like what happened to like
being able talk to people in your life
like communicate like normal
like not everything needs to be as dramatic as we make it on the internet
and I just think that like
everyone had become so obsessed with clicks and views
like they forgotten that the people in our screens are actual human beings
like they are people as well
it's just like
it's just so disappointing to watch
we need to bring back conflict resolution skill
we need to bring back interpersonal communication
like we just
we need to bring back being able to like
talk to people talk to your community
talk to your neighbours like
like the person that you're speaking to in your phone
is the same as the person next door
like not every fight also has to be like
the end of a relationship
I think it'd be really beneficial for people to be able to like
resolve a conflict within a relationship and then continue that relationship
you know what I mean obviously
like for people online maybe it's different
but like
in general I think we
as people
have kind of lapsed on our ability to resolve conflict within one another
but like
learn to pick up a phone like
honestly 99% of the time
when there's an issue that I have
I would rather call someone
like call a creator
call a friend call whoever
or speak to the face to face
and it's so much easier to handle the situation than texting
than social media then like
whatever it just like
I just really need people to learn how to communicate that's all